FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number 18
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
I'm very happy to be
back to California.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You've been out and about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I've been around, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
So we've got some
fun stuff today.
We are talking to Ian
Lewis about Bigtable.
It should be pretty exciting.
And we have a question
of the week talking
about some news bits and pieces
we announced recently as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, about how do
you know what you're
allowed to do on the cloud,
stuff like that-- how do
you make sure that people
don't do what they should not?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, just making
sure everything's locked down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And I'm actually very
excited about-- not really
the question, but
really the answer.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The answer
is going to be pretty cool.
But before that, so
today, right now,
like today, as on Wednesday--
MARK MANDEL: Especially if
you've downloaded this episode
as it came out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So it's actually one of
our days for Google Cloud
Platform, especially for us
Google Developer advocate.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
because it is GCP Next.
MARK MANDEL: The big Google
Cloud Platform conference.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
(LAUGHING) Yeah.
And it's very cool.
It's happening in San Francisco
Wednesday and Thursday.
And if you can attend,
you should definitely
come see us because we're
going to be hanging out
somewhere next to a sign
that says "Podcast."
But if you're cannot come, you
can still catch up with all
the new things that we're
going to be announcing.
There's two ways.
One of them, we
already mentioned it.
There was-- what was it?
MARK MANDEL: The
extended viewing parties.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Extended
viewing parties-- [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: Which I'd like
to make a short note on.
It has grown a lot
since last week.
I am very impressed with a
number of extended parties
that are happening.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, last week
we actually mentioned the fact
that there was some countries
in Africa, which is still,
it's pretty crazy they have
a huge amount of parties,
which is really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Massive amount.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
we were mentioning
that there was, I think,
what country was it that had
more than the whole of Europe?
MARK MANDEL: I actually can't
read it because there are so
many parties.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, Cameroon.
MARK MANDEL: It's
covering Nigeria.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cameroon
and, yeah, Nigeria
has a crazy amount
of viewing parties.
And we mentioned that
Europe didn't have as many.
Since then, we got
basically parties
in every single big city.
And I'm very happy to say
that Barcelona, which I said,
it was a little bit of
a pity that Barcelona
didn't have a party.
Because I'm from there.
They didn't have a party.
Now it has.
What about Sydney?
MARK MANDEL: Australia?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or Melbourne?
Australia, in general,
how did they go?
MARK MANDEL: Australia,
there's not a party.
I'm a little sad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, that so sad.
MARK MANDEL: I'm a
little disappointed.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I mean, yes, it's
in the middle of the night.
But, hey, Japan is doing it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, if
Japan can have a party,
then Australia can have a party.
I'm a little sad.
I'm a little bit heartbroken.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, but anyway, even
for Australian people that
are in the middle of the night
and don't know
what to do and they
want to know more about
Google Cloud Platform,
there's also some of our talks,
especially all the keynotes,
are going to be live streaming.
You can still catch up on the
conference through live stream.
Just over the internet.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so if you're awake
at that time wondering what to
do, maybe you should tune in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: I think so.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Actually, if you're awake
right now in the middle
of the night listening
to this podcast, thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is very nice of you.
[LAUGHTER]
Cool.
OK, so let's go talk with
our colleague Ian Lewis
MARK MANDEL: That sounds
like a great idea.
We are very pleased
today to be joined
by yet another of our
wonderful coworkers.
Ian Lewis, thank you so
much for joining us today.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: So, Ian, its
great to have you here.
I know you normally don't live
anywhere near San Francisco.
But why don't you
tell us a little bit
about yourself, what you
do, et cetera, et cetera,
so everyone gets to know you.
IAN LEWIS: Sure.
So I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud Platform team.
And I'm actually based
out of Tokyo, Japan.
So I normally spend
most of my time
over there and also in A-Pac,
so in the Asia-Pacific region.
But I'm here for GCP Next.
So I'm in town for the podcast,
so I can kind of hang out here
with you guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool,
and just for context,
Ian Lewis from Japan, you
speak very good English.
Where are you from?
IAN LEWIS: I'm originally
from Maryland, actually,
from near DC.
But I moved to Japan
about 10 years ago.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
It's nice to have someone
from the United States,
from time to time
in the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Now, hold on.
Wait a minute.
We have a lot of
Japanese listeners.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is true.
MARK MANDEL: Can you say
something in Japanese
for us say hello to them?
IAN LEWIS: [SPEAKING JAPANESE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very awesome.
I heard "Ian."
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think
you said maybe something
about your name or something?
IAN LEWIS: Yeah.
So basically, it's
an introduction.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
basically, the idea
for the episode for today was
since it was two episodes ago
that we had Paul?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
talked about storage.
And we basically covered the
whole spectrum of storage
and discussed about
what product to use,
when to use one or the other.
And I think that the most
interesting one, or at least
one of the most interesting
products, because it basically
powers Google, is Bigtable.
And it turns out that you
are pretty much the expert
in the team about Bigtable.
So could you tell
us a little bit
about what is Bigtable from
like, I think it's called,
10,000 feet view?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That 10,000 feet
sounds reasonable?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
14,000 feet view?
I don't know.
But from very high level.
IAN LEWIS: Right.
So there's quite a
difference, like there's
5,000 versus 10,000 feet,
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
IAN LEWIS: So bigtable is like
basically the NoSQL database.
It was the kind of
the original one THAT
started the whole NoSQL idea.
And so Google's been using
it for quite a long time
just as the kind
of go-to database
for its very large applications,
like Gmail and Search and Maps.
And it was originally published
kind of as a white paper.
And then the ideas around
the architecture of Bigtable
were incorporated
into open source
projects, like HBase and
Cassandra and things like that.
And so from a technical
point of view,
it's actually a key
value data store.
But it allows you to
have many values per key.
And then it allows you
to do range scans by key.
So in kind of relational
database parlance,
it's you have a
primary index, but you
don't have a secondary index.
So you have what's
basically called columns,
but those columns, you
can't actually index those,
so you can't do queries on
them and that sort of thing.
MARK MANDEL: So when you
say you can do a range scan,
what does that
kind of look like?
IAN LEWIS: So you can kind think
of the keys in the Bigtable
as being sorted by the00
lexicographically, basically.
And so they're basically
sorted, and you can pick a key
and say, OK, from this key,
I want to do a range scan of,
and then just basically continue
to iterate over those keys.
So you can say, so from
key A get 100 keys.
And then in that way, you can do
things like paging or whatnot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
So you can kind
of get whatever's
in that ordered range--
IAN LEWIS: Right, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very interesting.
So this is actually
sounds sort a little bit--
the story about Bigtable sounds
a little bit like MapReduce
where basically Google writes
a paper, and then at the end,
someone else implements
it, not Google.
So I'm assuming HBase
is the open source
implementation of Bigtable?
IAN LEWIS: Right, exactly.
And so HBase was an
open source project
that was created based on
the Bigtable white paper.
But now that
Bigtable is something
that we are releasing as
part of Cloud Platform,
so that other
developers can use it,
we decided to actually make it
available via the HBase API.
So you can use the
exact same API as HBase
in order to access
Bigtable, which
is pretty powerful because
Bigtable is completely fully
managed, and it makes it really
easy to set up and get running.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
I really like the idea
Google created Bigtable, not
open sourcing it, and
then making it available
and having the API
to something that was
created from the [INAUDIBLE].
IAN LEWIS: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I really
like open source community.
[INAUDIBLE] [? funny. ?]
IAN LEWIS: Well, I
think that Google
is kind of modifying their
stance a little bit on that.
So like things like
TensorFlow and Kubernetes
are things that are
kind of coming out
that where Google's actually
providing or creating
an open source implementation
that folks can kind of build
on, rather than just releasing
a white paper from the White
Tower, you know?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, no, I really like the
idea of now more like the paper
comes with code.
That's very nice.
IAN LEWIS: Ight.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So when I joined Google, I
joined as a software engineer.
And it's true what
you're saying.
Basically, everyone uses
Bigtable for everything.
But if you are not Google,
why could you use Bigtable?
IAN LEWIS: So there's
a few reasons why
you might want to use Bigtable.
So one is that
Bigtable's very fast.
You can make queries
on Bigtable or gets
and puts and things like
that, both reads and writes,
in about less than
tens of milliseconds.
So it's a very fast database.
At the same time, it's
also a database that
will scale to very large size.
So I mentioned that it's very
limited in what it can actually
do, like you only have
a primary key index.
But that those
limits actually allow
you to scale to very, very
large sizes, so things like,
basically many
petabytes in size.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
IAN LEWIS: But there
might be some use cases
where you would
want that, and that
would be like things like
time-series databases,
analytics.
Those are the ones that
are very easy to get
started using Bigtable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
You said that
Bigtable's really fast.
And you actually gave
the order of magnitude
about ten milliseconds.
For our listeners, what is the
order of magnitude of others,
like, for instance, like
Datastore or, for instance,
on MySQL databases?
IAN LEWIS: So MySQL
will be pretty
fast for things like
basically getting by key
or selecting by key.
But for things like
very complex queries,
it could take
orders of magnitude
longer, like many, many seconds
or many tens of seconds.
And things like
Datastore generally
come back in the tens of
milliseconds or hundreds
of milliseconds,
depending on the queries
that you're actually doing, So
Bigtable is quite a bit faster,
and so, in that sense, it's
very good for kind of more
low latency applications.
MARK MANDEL: And I'm
guessing you probably
don't have similar
issues, like you would
with, say, MySQL, where once
a table gets really large,
you start having like
slowdowns and stuff like that.
IAN LEWIS: Right, exactly.
So I mentioned that MySQL will
be fast for keys, selecting
just a key, but it will
actually get much slower
when it's actually overloaded
or gets very large.
MARK MANDEL: So
we're basically sort
of thinking so Bigtable
probably exists for those really
big data applications.
IAN LEWIS: Right, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There's actually
one of my favorite things
that you can do with Bigtable,
and which we used for a
funny demo for Pi Day.
It's the fact that
you don't need
to know the whole key,
that you can just say,
give me all the keys that
starts with this prefix.
IAN LEWIS: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Could you tell--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, is
that how that works?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is
pretty amazing, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
you can be like, oh,
I'm actually just storing
keys of like 10 words.
But if you give me
only five, I will still
find it because I
can say, give me
all the keys that start
with those five words--
five letters, sorry.
IAN LEWIS: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is pretty amazing.
So I was able to
make it for my case,
but that's a very
specific and weird thing
to do to search stuff on pi.
But have you ever seen people
doing these kind of things
in production, and what for?
IAN LEWIS: So, yeah, that's
a great thing to mention.
So Bigtable allows you to
do several different types
of what they call filters, and
one of those is a prefix scan.
And so you can select
all of the keys that
have a particular prefix.
And so you might
use that for things
like indexing, for instance.
Like in your case, you actually
indexed numbers of pi, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
IAN LEWIS: And then you can
go and search those later.
Well, you can do the
same sort of thing
with text or with
just regular old keys.
So this is actually
what Datastore
uses to do its secondary indexes
for when you actually save
entities and things like that.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So you could use like common
prefixes to group things
together and things like that?
IAN LEWIS: Yes.
Yes, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So then I think
that everybody then
is convinced that actually
Datastore is amazing.
Ah, Datastore-- sorry.
Bigtable's amazing, and
everybody should be using it.
But that's not the
case, even at Google.
So why could someone
not use Bigtable?
IAN LEWIS: Yeah, so
there's a few reasons,
and these are the kind of
reasons why Datastore exists.
So Bigtable doesn't actually
support transactions.
So it actually will
support allowing
you to write a single
row, and that row
will be written or not written.
So in that sense, you can
basically do transactions
on a single set of
columns or a single row,
but you can't actually
do that across rows.
So if you want to save
multiple rows at the same time,
you need some other kind of
transaction or locking-kind-of
mechanism.
It's also not the
greatest database
for things like
high availability.
So if you have a
particular key, that key
may become unavailable
kind of sporadically,
depending on how that
database is being split up
and moved around
in the back end.
And so if you need your database
to be like completely highly
available and for the keys
to be there all of the time,
then Bigtable might not
be exactly what you want.
You also have the issue
of it being local.
So it's local to
a specific region.
And so you can do replication to
other regions in the background
or asynchronously.
But if you need your database
to be kind of globally
available or
something like that,
then Bigtable might
not be something
that you'll want to have.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yeah, that makes sense.
What about the cost?
Because how do you
pay for a Bigtable?
Is it like Datastore, where
you pay per operation, or?
IAN LEWIS: Right.
So Bigtable's actually a
little bit more predictable
than Datastore.
So Bigtable, actually,
you pay for the cost,
and then you pay
for the nodes that
are set up to allow
you to make queries
on the database and
that sort of thing.
And so what you pay for is like
per-hour per-node as well as
the storage in per gigabyte.
I don't remember exactly
what it is right now,
but the minimum cost for
the nodes is about $1,400
per month plus storage.
So you pay in that sense.
And so I mentioned nodes,
and that's something
that I think that I
should probably mention
is that there are nodes
that you set up in Bigtable,
and you pay per node.
But these nodes
basically provide you
throughput into the database.
So you basically get
about 10,000 queries
per second per node.
And so if you need
more than say 30,000,
which is the minimum--
three nodes is the minimum.
If you need more than 30,000,
then you'll set up more nodes
and basically allow you to
do more throughput there.
MARK MANDEL: So really, as your
throughput requirements grow,
the more nodes
you're going to need.
Therefore your cost increases,
and you can trade that off.
IAN LEWIS: Right, exactly.
But what's interesting
about Bigtable
is that the nodes actually
don't store the data.
The data is stored separately.
And so you can kind of
increase and decrease
the number of nodes like pretty
separately from how much data
you store.
So say you have a lot of
data, but you don't actually
need that many QPS.
You can actually just
have it three nodes.
And your storage can
be astronomically big,
but you're just using
three nodes to access it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And what
is that, that there's
a minimum of three nodes?
IAN LEWIS: So the
minimum of three nodes
is basically there to allow
a little bit of redundancy
for the nodes, because
those can be kind of moved
around a little bit also.
But basically, when you
create a Bigtable cluster,
essentially you have a minimum
of three nodes to set up.
And so that's
basically kind of a way
of allowing kind of a minimal
level of service for Bigtable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So something that I used for
the pi finder for that demo
was actually that idea of being
able to add nodes and remove
them.
And I was lucky
enough that I got
to work with the Bigtable team.
So I ran a data flow process,
where I was processing
a huge amount of data.
I mean, pi big.
And on top of that, I
was storing everything
to Bigtable at the same time.
So I was able to run a Bigtable
cluster with 500 nodes.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
IAN LEWIS: Quite awesome
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
was incredibly amazing.
I had like, I think it
was, like over 1,000 nodes
in data flow trying to
basically write as much as I
could directly to Bigtable.
And Bigtable didn't even
shake. [? It was ?] amazing.
MARK MANDEL: What sort of
throughput were you getting?
Do you know?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Actually, I
didn't look all the time at it.
But I know that it
passed really, really
fast one million requests per
second, really, really easily.
And I was like, oh, wow.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And then the good thing
is that once it was done
and it had all pi
stored in Bigtable,
I took it down to three.
And everything went
really fast, which
is very nice, because then it's
like oh, yeah, I'm done now.
I have my process already done.
Like if you're
running map reduce
or whatever, once the
map reduce is over,
if you need to read from it,
you don't need those nodes,
like all the nodes you
had at the beginning.
And that's really cool.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah.
That's one benefit of me
being on the same team
is I've seen the same exact
things that you guys have.
But, yeah, I think
the graph was actually
about close to two million.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Two million, wow.
IAN LEWIS: Which is
pretty impressive.
MARK MANDEL: Well, what's
one and two million?
I mean, like it's
the same number.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah, you
can also say, though,
that we do have customers that
do quite a bit more than that.
So it's a database that scales.
Internally, we
also have customers
that do very, very large
amounts of queries per second.
And I also mentioned that it's
like 10 milliseconds per query.
But that basically
doesn't change no matter
the size of the data
as well as that's
also like a P99 type of thing.
So basically, 99% of the
queries will be faster
than 10 milliseconds.
So it's very, very
consistent in terms
of how fast the
queries are, which
is very advantageous
for a lot of use cases.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
OK.
So let's imagine that I
wanted to use Bigtable,
but I'm actually using
something different,
like for instance,
I'm using Datastore.
How big of a change could
that be for the developer?
IAN LEWIS: Yeah, that could
be quite a big change.
It depends on what you're
doing with Datastore.
If you're doing things that are
very kind of low level, where
you're only doing
gets and puts by key,
then that can translate
pretty easily to Bigtable.
And so I think it wouldn't
be too hard to migrate.
But other things, where
you're doing lots of queries
and you're using
lots of indexes,
those types of situations would
be pretty difficult to move
over, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And what
about if I was already using
HBase and I wanted
to use Bigtable?
IAN LEWIS: So that's
a good question.
So the Bigtable does
support the HBase API.
There's a few of edge cases,
that it doesn't support.
Those are mostly around
managing the HBase,
so like doing compactions
and adding nodes and things
like that.
And Bigtable's kind
of fully managed,
so you don't really have
to deal with any of that.
But there are a few like
kind of small edge cases
that it doesn't support.
But, for the most
part, it supports
the majority of the HBase API.
And so it's very,
very easy to move
from an HBase installation or an
HBase cluster over to Bigtable.
Probably the hardest thing
will be moving the data over.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's fair enough.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
before we wrap up here,
is there anything about
Bigtable you want to mention
or anything else that we
may have managed to miss?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Any cool project
that you would like to mention
that you've seen before,
other than my thing
searching for pi.
I'm sure the people have
more interesting stuff
than searching pi.
IAN LEWIS: So Google has made
quite a lot of cool projects,
and all of them pretty
much use Bigtable.
But what I think is
interesting about Bigtable
is that it's used
kind of at Google
as the basis for a lot of
other types of data stores.
And so things like Datastore
and Cloud Datastore
are kind of built
on top of Bigtable
to allow like secondary
indexes and things like that.
So I think that
like how Bigtable
is used kind of as a low-level
storage is pretty interesting.
And I think that just the sheer
scale and the amount of work
that's gone into it at
Google is quite amazing.
We've spent probably about a
year and millions of man hours
improving Bigtable.
And so it's very,
very optimized when
you compare it to things
like HBase and Cassandra.
Cassandra can do things
like, it can write very fast,
but it can't read very fast.
But Bigtable can
kind of do both.
And so it's very,
very interesting
that it can read really
fast and write really
fast and get really big.
So it's almost like
this magical thing
that we've been able to improve
and build upon over the last 10
years or so.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Ian, thank you
so much for joining us.
Really appreciate
you taking the time.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah,
it's been great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
IAN LEWIS: Thanks.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
so much to Ian
for joining us for
that interview.
I learned a whole lot.
I really didn't
actually know very much
at all about Bigtable.
And now I have a
much better idea.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, no, Bigtable's
a very, very cool product,
and it is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, once you get
started and you start
using it-- and have not
seen the point where it's like,
oh, yeah, it's not slow enough.
Nope, not there yet.
MARK MANDEL: No.
No.
Excellent.
But we do have a very
interesting Question
of the Week.
The question kind of comes from
managing, say, a Google Cloud
Platform project.
And within that
project, you probably
have a whole bunch
of different things.
Like maybe you have stuff
deployed to App Engine,
stuff to push into
Cloud Storage, maybe
stuff on Compute
Engine instances.
And you have someone new join
your team, and you want to say,
oh, OK, I want them to be able
to deploy, say, Compute Engine
instances, but I don't want
them to be able to read
from, say, Cloud Storage.
Maybe you have like
private keys there
or something like that, that
are only limited to certain team
members.
Can you do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
no, until today, actually.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, until today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Until
today-- until today right
now, Wednesday,
March 23rd-- 23rd.
MARK MANDEL: 23rd.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
23rd, that's it. (LAUGHING)
I'm really bad with dates.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
actually today we announced
this really cool thing,
which is Cloud I-A-M-- I-A-M,
or Cloud "I am"
or Cloud "ee-um,"
if you want to pronounce
it in a weird way.
MARK MANDEL: So Cloud Identity
and Access Management.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If you
want to be correct, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
basically, it allows you to,
basically, you talk
about what things
are people allowed to do.
So far, we had three roles
in Google Cloud Platform.
We had the role of
honor, that was basically
allowed to do anything;
the role of editor, that
was allowed to do some things
MARK MANDEL: Most things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Most
things, but not everything.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then
the role of viewer, that was
allows us to view things
but not like create
an instance of [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very limited.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so if I
wanted to grant someone access,
they pretty much got
access to mostly all of it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, basically.
So now you can actually
create way more roles,
and we already did that.
We created a bunch
of different roles.
So for instance, you
can say, oh, actually
someone is going to be a Compute
Engine instance administrator.
So that person will be
allowed to create instances,
to delete them if needed.
But they will not be able to
modify a Google Cloud Storage
bucket for instance.
MARK MANDEL: So you can really
tailor exactly what permission
levels people have within
the system to exactly
what your business needs are.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
And that building on top of
the best practice of using
multiple projects for
different environments,
you could see
something where you
can have like [INAUDIBLE]
[? action ?] environment,
like production product,
QA product, test product.
And you have different
roles for those people.
So someone would be able to do--
like everybody will be an honor
and be allowed to do everything
in the project for [? tests. ?]
But maybe in QA you cannot
do all of those things.
And maybe in production
you're able not to do anything
unless you are a DevOps
and then you are actually
allowed to dig down
instances and delete data
and do crazy things like that.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
And I'm guessing yo probably
also like build tools as well.
So like you can't physically
go in and modify stuff,
but if you go through the
administration console,
like a custom-built thing or
like some DevOps-type scripting
environment, then you're
like, OK, that's OK.
But then it sort of
mitigates how much
problems you can kind of
do by just kind of poking
around and seeing
what sort of things
happen when I put a spanner
in the electrical socket.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: (LAUGHING)
Yeah, you should not do that.
MARK MANDEL: You should
probably not do that.
Don't do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Kids, don't do that.
Yeah, and on top of that,
there's also the fact
that when I say
identity, it kind of
sounds like it's only
for people but not only.
You can have the same
thing for instances
or any kind of machines but
by using service accounts.
So you can basically
say, oh, this instance
is allowed to read
from this bucket,
or these instance is able to--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we used to
have those things as tokens.
You kind of have the same
granularity of-- sorry.
Not tokens-- scopes
for [INAUDIBLE].
You have this kind of same
idea for every single one
of the roles applied to every
single one of the resources.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So not only can you really
nail it down by user,
but you can be like,
yeah, this part could only
access this particular part.
This part can only access
this particular part.
And you can get much
more secure about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, basically, you
get all the enhanced security
that a company like Google
could need.
Until now, it could be really
weird to have something like
a big, big company,
where in a big,
big company you cannot trust
every single engineer to do
every single thing, Now you
can actually write it down.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, yeah,
very excited about this,
and very excited to see
how people welcome it.
I'm pretty sure that there was a
lot of people waiting for this.
MARK MANDEL: I think so, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
pretty sure there's
someone there listening
to this podcast right now
just cheering.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
I was talking to a
listener recently
who said they almost crashed
their car from an episode
at the end of the
day because they
threw their hands in
the air and did not
grip the steering wheel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Was
it the Kubernetes one?
MARK MANDEL: It was
the Kubernetes one.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So,
people, if you're listening
to this podcast while driving--
MARK MANDEL: Hold on
to your steering wheel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
(LAUGHING) Yeah.
It is dangerous otherwise.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, Francesc, thank you
very much for joining us
for yet another episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you
very much for having me.
Very happy to be here.
And let's see what's
coming next week.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh.
Maybe we'll have
something special.
I mean, we're at Google Cloud
Platform Next today, right now.
MARK MANDEL: We are indeed.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
maybe something special
will come next week.
MARK MANDEL: We shall see.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Until next week.
MARK MANDEL: Until then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]